You're donating your kidney to--
A stranger.
Right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think the coolest part about
donating a kidney to a stranger
is I may have absolutely nothing
in common with my recipient.
Organ transplants cross racial
divides, social divides,
political divides.
It's such a visceral reminder
of how we really are completely
the same.
That is a gift.
My name's Hendrik Gerrits.
In a week and a half, I'm
going to be giving my kidney
to a complete stranger.
I'm 37.
I'm a long distance runner,
a recent rock climber,
and the father of
two beautiful girls.
My wife, Lumin, is a painter.
I've lived in two places in
my life, Wyoming and New York.
I just remember traveling
home on the subway.
I, probably like a
lot of Americans,
was getting pretty
overwhelmed with the news.
And I just felt like
I was in this rut.
And I heard this amazing
story from this woman
Christine Gentry on one of my
favorite podcasts called Risk!
And she found out that
by donating her kidney,
she could set off a
chain of donations.
And I just remember it was one
of those crying-on-the-subway
moments as you heard this story.
I was overwhelmed by
the power of the story
but also just immediately
felt like, that's my thing.
I knew I could do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We are eight days away
from my operation,
and I'm here to meet
for the first time
with Dr. Del Pizzo,
who will be my surgeon.
I'm really excited about that.
I am trying to imagine that this
is something like a race day
scenario.
I need to be able
to visualize what
it's going to be like, what the
recovery is going to be like.
But I feel like I'm going
in to meet with my coach.
Hi, how are you?
Dr. Del Pizzo.
Joe Del Pizzo, good to see you.
Nice to meet you.
Welcome.
Thanks.
Have a seat.
Thanks
I have a couple of
questions for you.
OK.
You're donating your kidney to--
--a stranger.
Right.
So you're an altruistic donor.
So thank you for doing that.
Yeah.
We are going to use your
left kidney for the donation.
OK.
Your left kidney.
Both of your kidneys
work exactly the same.
Your body's not going to
miss one more than the other.
OK.
And the surgery is done
through one little incision
in your belly button.
It's called laparoendoscopic
single-site surgery.
Your body won't recognize that
you have one kidney versus two.
OK.
And it won't adversely
affect the rest of your life
in any way.
If it did, we wouldn't
let you or anyone else
donate their kidney.
Yeah.
You're not only helping
the person who's
getting your kidney on
the 19th, but that person
is going to come off the
list of people waiting
for a kidney in the country,
and everyone else on the list
is going to move up.
Yeah.
So you are helping
thousands of people.
So you're already
part of a huge team.
Yeah.
OK.
All right?
Well, thanks so much.
Good to meet you.
Looking forward to it.
Thanks again for everything, OK?
Yeah, OK.
I'll see you soon.
OK, see you.
A non-directed kidney donor
is someone like myself
who just wants to
help someone in need.
The power of that gift is
that I'm giving a kidney,
but don't need a
kidney in return.
And what that can do is
unlock all of this potential
in the paired donor exchange.
So there are all of these
pairs floating out there,
but the difficulty
is matching them up.
I found out that
they found my match,
and she's a 20-year-old woman
who lives on the East Coast.
And it's just very overwhelming.
As an non-directed
donor you very much
have to be prepared to
not meet your recipient.
I can only imagine
the difficulties
that she must be
going through now.
Not only that, but she
has a hero in her own life
who's donating a
kidney on her behalf
so that she can
receive my kidney.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Dialysis is not an
easy thing for sure.
You're very tired,
lethargic all the time.
It does take a toll.
Just, you're so tired.
So I hook up to this every night
for nine, nine and half hours
a night.
My name is Kali,
I'm 21 years old.
Depending on what time she
has to leave in the morning
is what time she has
to hook up at night.
At six months old, my
doctor diagnosed me
with nephrotic syndrome.
And at five years old,
I ended up on dialysis.
And at six years old, I
received a kidney transplant
from a deceased donor.
In February 2017, they
started to realize
my kidney was rejecting.
By October, I was
back on dialysis.
I had to put my
dreams on hold and I
had to stop going to school.
They said that it was going
to be a pretty hard match.
On a scale of 0 to 100
antibody scale, with 100
being you're a really hard
match, they said I was 99.
The doctors told me I should
definitely share my story
to just get the word out.
And see if there are people
that would want to be a donor.
Tracy, my friend of five
years, came forward.
I stepped forward
to become a donor
so that I could try to help
Kali and give her the life
that she deserves.
Even though I'm not a
direct match for Kali,
I am a match for
somebody out there.
Hendrik is giving
his kidney to Kali,
and Tracy, who really
wanted to give her
a kidney but wasn't a match,
gave it to someone else.
And if that person
who got a kidney also
has someone who is willing
to donate for them,
there's another kidney
that's still out there
that goes to another person.
And that's how a chain develops.
So this kind of pay
it forward mentality.
It's a win-win situation,
because by stepping forward
as a donor, I'm
able to help Kali.
And at that same time, I'm
helping a complete stranger
who's also in dire
need of a kidney.
Tomorrow I'll be
receiving a kidney
from a complete stranger.
I'm so grateful.
I just can't wait.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
It is November 19,
it's about 7:00 AM.
And I'm about to
donate my left kidney.
This is Urethra
Franklin The Second,
who's named after Christine
Gentry's kidney, who's
the woman who inspired my story.
I really hope that
this kidney goes
on to a very fruitful
life for a long time.
So--
I think that 15 minute
period right beforehand
is kind of the scariest moment.
Because the reality of
the situation sets in.
But then I felt a sense of calm.
And I felt like I'd
prepared myself for some
of those nerves and fear.
20 years ago, in order
to donate your kidney,
you had to have a
major operation.
The whole point of developing
the minimally invasive
technique, which we've
taken a step further
at NewYork-Presbyterian
Weill Cornell,
was to decrease
the disincentives
for healthy people to
donate their kidney.
You guys ready to do
a surgical time out?
You make a 3 inch incision
in the bellybutton area.
Starting--
And through that incision
goes a small device
where you can put
instruments through.
And one of those
instruments is a camera
that then projects onto a
large high-definition screen.
You basically remove the
kidney from all its attachments
except for the blood supply
and the ureter, which
is the small tube that
carries urine from your kidney
down to your bladder.
Unbeknownst to Hendrik, Kali
was getting her transplant
in the next room.
And Tracy was in the
hospital as well.
There were basically three
simultaneous surgeries
going on.
Hendrik's kidney
was removed, then
that was taken across
and given to Dr. Sultan.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
He starts the recipient surgery,
and I'm back in Hendrik's room
finishing up the surgery.
The third surgery that day
was when Tracy's kidney
was harvested and was
safely and successfully
removed to be flown to another
hospital in the country
to use in another recipient as
part of the paired exchange.
When I woke up from
anesthesia, groggily I
remember my mom
and my wife's face.
And they said everything had
gone well, but even better,
they said that my recipient
was at the hospital.
And that she really
wanted to meet me.
It was incredibly emotional.
I was very excited.
It was a dream scenario, really.
Hi.
[PIANO MUSIC]
How are you?
Really good.
[LAUGHTER]
I have a letter for you.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Did you get my letter?
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, read it after I was
conscious that day, so.
Yeah.
You feeling good?
Feeling better?
Really good.
Great.
I took good care of
it, it's a good kidney.
They said it took so quick.
Never seen--
Good.
--a kidney work so quick.
Yeah.
That's great.
So.
I'm so happy for you.
Sounds like you got so
much in front of you.
Yeah.
And my--
Got a whole new life.
Yeah.
Because I was on
the deceased donor
list at my local
hospital, and they said
it was going to be at
least six to seven years.
Whoa.
So--
That's too long.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I mean, we don't even know how--
Yeah.
--to thank you.
It's just been a
really long journey.
I bet.
Yeah, the number one
thing is freedom.
I'm going to have more freedom.
I was completely overwhelmed.
And I think unprepared
for the feeling
of meeting a complete
stranger with whom you feel
such a visceral connection.
I didn't know the
first thing about her,
but I felt intensely
invested in her well-being.
Hi I'm Kali's mom.
Hi.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Nice to meet you.
Thanks.
[INAUDIBLE]
Thank you.
And you're right there in
writing, you are Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you.
It's December 18, almost
a month after my surgery.
And we are about to go
meet with Dr. Sultan.
Over the past month, I've
been feeling incredible.
From the day I had my
surgery up until now,
it's just been night and day.
I feel great, I have
so much more energy.
And I can eat what I want
and drink what I want,
which is incredible.
How are you?
So, how's it going?
Amazing.
It was pretty
striking how quickly
the creatinine came down.
I've never seen
something like that.
The kidney cleans your blood
and clears out the creatinine.
So the lower the
creatinine the better.
So this is going
all the way back
when I first saw
you in February.
And then this is right
before the transplant.
And then really immediately
after the transplant,
it was already down to 10.
And that's within an hour or so.
And then by the next
morning it's way down.
And that's just a sign
that your kidney has been
working like a normal person.
Already you've kind of
dropped below the blue,
which is normal.
So you're better than normal.
Wow.
The donor's kidney function
was really quite excellent.
Thank you.
Dialysis is behind her.
She has no chances of needing
dialysis any time soon.
It's heartwarming to
see someone so young
get a new chance on life.
It's a funny thing
to say, but I was
very happy to have given
her such a good one.
Immediately after
my kidney donation,
I experienced a complication
that happens less than 1%
of the time.
I had to undergo a second
surgery to correct the issue.
After the second
surgery, my recovery
was really quite quick.
Four to six weeks
after surgery, I
was able to go to
the climbing gym
again and start climbing
with Liv and Lumin.
And that's just been wonderful.
Everyone should have
the chance to live,
and to live a full life.
It's not just their
life, but the other
lives they touch or create.
It's absolutely overwhelming
to have the honor
to even be a small part
of making that possible.
Riding the New York City subways
has been a profoundly different
experience for me lately.
I just don't see strangers
as strangers anymore.
It's quite a gift, so.
[MUSIC PLAYING]